jack  nicholson yeah when did you meet jack  because i've met jack a few times  at the lakers out of lake that's where i  met him too yes i was in the back room  with jack nicholson  in that back cigar in the cigar room  that was  well i was there and i was sitting there  talking to him  and i go man that's a shame you know  they need shaq to be back in the game  because he was injured or something he's  like yeah well you know it's like if you  know he starts talking about this and  that and everything's fine and we're  having a nice conversation about the  lakers and the season he doesn't miss a  game and all of a sudden this guy comes  up to him and goes hey jack this game  isn't as good as it gets is it and he  goes  if you'll excuse me and then [ __ ] and i  looked at the guy you [ __ ]  i was just talking to nicholson you  [ __ ] it up